um
okay so we're going to talk about
synaesthesia
and i'm going to be throwing some some
greek terms around but i'll give you you
know definitions of them
this won't presume any sort of
background knowledge on your part if you
go to wikipedia and you look up
synaesthesia you're going to be a little
bit disappointed
in part because the only thing that it
brings up is a pathological condition
and they give this as the definition
for for that pathological condition it's
where people can't turn it off
so they look at numbers and it evokes
sounds or colors or smells or things
like that
and you know why does that happen
um there's certain things that you could
you could take that would also promote
that you know certain
certain drugs sometimes people get
damaged in the brain
and that happens to them
the reason that it happens at least what
what we're going to look at with the
aristotle with maryland polti
is because it's actually part of what's
going on with our normal experience we
just don't realize it
and what you guys have been asked to do
by professor shaka
is to think about how things connect up
together how tastes and smells and
sounds
and even larger units of meaning like
music
can evoke each other can promote each
other so
this definition that they give that i
put right off the bat you know from
wikipedia it's not bad but it's a little
restrictive
perceptual experience so right it's
about perception
you guys all experience
things all the time not all of your
experience is necessarily perceptual
when you have that aha moment because
you solved a difficult problem that's
not perception that's that's intellect
right
when you're planning out what you're
going to do
in the kitchen next
that's anticipation that's not
perception either memory is is based on
perception but it's not exactly the same
thing right
so perceptual experience in which a
stimulus and one modality and what you
ask what a modality is it's a one way
you know or one
um
one
manner in which things get to us so if
we're thinking about perception normally
we think in terms of what five senses
although that's a little inexact because
touch covers
pressure and heat and cold and all this
other
stuff so maybe we have to talk about you
know more if we want to be more reactive
but we have different modes so like
right now i'm looking at you i see the
white of your
your
chef's coat you know the black of your
hair
um
the gray of the the sharpie those are
things that are coming to me through the
mode of sight
we're hearing this weird noise
somebody's moving something around we
can't see them but we can we can hear
them right that's another mode
so
you know now imagine what's going on
upstairs
you can't actually see it but you can
kind of see in your mind's eye
you're already doing something like this
you know what color is the the um shirt
of the guy who's moving stuff around
like black blue
who knows right but you're imagining
something right and what really messes
you up is that i thought we were on the
top floor
oh there's another staircase that goes
up
our sense of spatiality is connected
with our senses as well so now one
modality gives rise to experience in
indifference sensory so somebody says
chocolate to you and it's a it's a word
you're hearing it and suddenly you taste
chocolate like if you have a really
active imagination
or if you can't turn it off
then you know this could be that
pathological condition we're not so
concerned with that we're interested
more in how can you make this work for
you how can you cultivate
synesthetic
understanding of things synesthetic
imagination because you're going to be
chefs and you're going to be trying to
think about what it is that you're
making and you're also going to try to
be able to articulate to other people to
explain it to other people in language
not just you know putting in front of
them saying here you go eat right
there's more to being a chef than just
making good food it has to do with your
imagination it has to do with your
intellect it has to do with your ability
to communicate
it has to do with all those sorts of
things
but you're communicating largely about
perception about senses
so i've got these other words here
and i want to kind of expand it a little
bit notice that i'm not just talking
about
you know stimulus and sensory modalities
i'm using a bigger word here of
meaning
meaning is not just
things like black
or
fast or slow you know when it comes to
sound
or
bitter or or sweet
meaning
is
broader than that it comprises i'll show
you you know in a few minutes how
aristotle and marilyn maltea think about
that but look at these words new
transfer sets
so when you guys are thinking about a
dish
and you let's say you're doing an
exercise like what you did here today
but you're doing it the other way around
instead of having a piece of music
that evokes something for you
you actually
you want to create a dish and you want
that dish to communicate
something to the person who's eating it
like let's you know some of you talked
about home
what is it about
a particular dish
and let's assume that we're all on the
same page with like you know what
constitutes home and comfort food i know
we're not because you know different
cultures and things like that but let's
just say we we are for the most part
you could ask yourself okay what could i
do
that would communicate that would have
meaning of
home of comfort of settling in
of these sorts of things
scent what sensory impressions would
they have to create
i mean would you pick things that are
super bold
you know
lots of color and
spicy peppers and things like that
i don't know if that's your home maybe
but not for most of us i think
so that's stuff that you could think
about
transferring meaning
from one domain to another that's part
of what you do as chefs
you may you may have never thought of
that before
but you're transferring meaning from
first of all from your your imagination
and your memory
into actual physical things which are
going to be transferred as kind of
procedures into people's mouths right
where they're going to taste things that
first they were seeing and now they're
tasting
and then they're going to communicate
about it and you're probably going to go
to the table too what do you think you
like it not like it what did you taste
in there right
that's all about
meaning
sometimes there's slippage going on
you don't necessarily intend everything
that that goes into it
it's because meaning is is generally
bigger than just what we intend or
things bleed over into each other
a dish can go wrong right
an ambiance that you create again in
front of the house sort of issue rather
than a back of the house issue
an ambiance can actually ruin a meal you
can't even bad service can ruin a meal a
meal that's
perfectly prepared in the back of the
house perfectly plated
everything is cooked exactly as it ought
to be it can come up there and
some sort of meaning can bleed over into
another
and then i like this word evocation this
is another thing to think about when
you're designing a dish or when you're
modifying a dish what are you trying to
evoke
in the person just like you know an
artist who is thinking about what do
they want their music to evoke in
somebody else or you know painter
or an architect how do they want people
to experience space you guys are working
with perceptual experience
of your your clients and of course you
because you're gonna eat your own stuff
too right you like eating that's part of
why you're here i think
um
so you're gonna do this as well um
now marilyn pontig
has some interesting things to say about
synaesthesia and actually i'm just going
to read
one passage
he's reacting against
um
he's reacting against the kind of
mentality that a lot of people have
uh about
um
how does that that our senses connect up
with each other a lot of people see it
as sort of like you know the senses give
us units of meaning and our brains just
kind of process them and you know
create you know something going on in
there that's not the only way that you
can look yet
um there's a
a
particularly pre-modern way
and that's where a lot of your
traditions of cooking come from too from
pre-modern sources
of looking at the way in which we
experience things as human beings in the
world engaged with our our senses that
doesn't reduce it down to just data just
what can be measured
and reproduced and perhaps you know
turned into something that this could
experience just as much as as you or i
could experience
so merrill ponti um was talking about
synaesthesia and he says
seen in the perspective of the objective
world with the opaque qualities in the
objective body with the separate organs
the phenomenon of synesthetic experience
is paradoxical what does that mean
paradoxical hard to explain hard to wrap
your head around
it doesn't compute
so there's certain ways of looking at
the world
certain ways of looking at your
perceptual experience that the sort of
thing you just did in class
doesn't make any sense
how can sight be sound be taste be how
can all these things mean each other how
can you look at that and say
it's got spidery legs
you know
or say
this looks hard
right
or say
the book
the pages
look
as if they would be
soft to the touch
right how are you able to do that that's
what synesthesia actually is
he says the attempt is made to explain
it independently of the concept of
sensation so you know people think that
you just you know turn it into a brain
issue and he says whether or not this
explanation is supported by arguments
drawn from brain physiology this
explanation doesn't account for
synesthetic experience
for the subject doesn't say only that he
has a sensation of both a sound and a
color some people hear a sound and it
evokes a color
and i'm not just talking about somebody
says blue and now you think about blue
i'm talking about i say ocean
does the color blue sort of pop into
your mind
you're having a synesthetic experience
right there right
the subject does not say only that he
has the sensation both of the sound and
the color it's the sound itself that he
sees when colors are formed the
formation is literally meaningless if
vision is defined by by the visual
quality and sound by the acoustic and so
he's going on with this and i'm going to
skip over a little bit he says
synesthetic perception is the rule
which means that
whether you realize it or not that's the
way your brain actually works
you're having synesthetic experience all
the time you're just not conscious of it
most of the time it's lying below the
threshold of your consciousness
now
why does what does this have to do with
you
part of what you're going to be doing is
as you're training as chefs is learning
how to bring it above
into your conscious
dimension so that you can actually work
with it so that you can shape it
so that you can become better and better
at predicting how it's going to pan out
for people who you're creating dishes
for
because everybody's going through this
everybody is seeing things which evoke
sounds which evoke
tastes which evoke smells which evoke
other units of meaning for them all the
time
that's why you can look at you know you
can look at a passageway and say i don't
want to go down there
and says why why not i don't know it
just looks scary
really
how does it actually look scary
well it has that meaning
you know does that mean that you just
sort of like predict like a computer and
there's a probability if i go down there
i might get mugged this looks like the
kind of place where i might get mugged
no what's going on is you actually
perceive scariness out there
in the world and marilyn ponte is doing
a kind of philosophical
method that's called phenomenology where
you're being very attentive to our
experience and how we put it together
good chefs whether they realize it or
not are actually also very good
phenomenologists
um they may not have read maryland
but they're doing sort of the thing that
he's talking about here so he says
synesthetic perception is the rule and
we're unaware of it only because
scientific knowledge shifts the center
of gravity of experience we've unlearned
how to see
hear
and generally speaking feel
we've become kind of
detached
and the more that we learn about the
scientific way of looking at things
which is really a very abstract way of
seeing things
the less we pay attention to what's
actually in front of us and how it feels
how it sounds how it smells and so you
guys are you guys are in the process now
of learning how to pay more and more
attention right that's part of what's
going on in your
your your classes they have you taste
things they tell you tell me what you're
tasting
why does it taste that way
how does it compare to other things how
would you replicate that you know
and as time goes on your palate is going
to get more and more refined
that's you actually becoming more
attentive to
experience um so like he says sight it
said can only bring us colors or lights
i think he's right you know your eyeball
you guys know about how the science of
your eyeball right what what's what's in
there
besides you know boo and
lenses and things like that what's in
the back do you remember from your
classes right you got the retina and
then cornea
yeah and that's letting light in and
what's that light actually hitting
got those rods and cones in back there
and those are just like receptors
they're on they're off they're like your
taste buds right
how do your taste buds work they're
basically sort of on off machines
but that's not actual
sense
that's not the meaning that you're
you're experiencing that's all that's
going on with the organ your eyeball
but is that did any of you actually see
little tiny pixels being put together
i hope not you do i need to go to the
doctor because there's something wrong
with your with your brain that's not
actually wrong with your eyes your eyes
are doing what they're supposed to be
but they're not being put together the
right way the information so he says
sighted set can only bring us colors or
lights and with them forms which are the
outlines of colors and movements which
are the patches of color changing
position that's all that you know let's
say that this was actually you know a
really really smart phone it could like
you know make predictions about what
people are doing and read faces and all
that sort of stuff all i'd be doing is
taking in
patches of color
that's all the camera can do the camera
does that really well better than your
eye
but that's all it does it doesn't
generate
meaning
how shall we place transparency or muddy
colors in the scale
muddy colors if i say
you know this is kind of a muddy red
you understand what i'm saying don't you
you can relate to it that is meaning for
you
now if all that was going on with your
eyes was seeing just colors that
wouldn't make sense muddy is in a
different
realm i guess maybe the the realm of
touch isn't it you guys know what mud
feels like don't you you're transferring
that meaning onto this surface which
you're taking in with your eyes
um
it says in reality each color and its
innermost depth is nothing but the inner
structure of the thing overtly revealed
the brilliance of gold he talks about
the dull color of wood
that makes sense to you and i read that
doesn't it you can picture that
but is wood really dull to the eye
it's dull to other things you're
transferring meaning meaning is bleeding
over from one thing to another he says
the senses intercommunicate by opening
up onto the structure of the thing now
imagine that in terms of a dish
the things that you guys are talking
about tonight
your sense is opening up onto the
structure of the thing making sense of
what it is
think about the taste of a beer
or
when you bite into a piece of chicken or
what else
would you bring up though yeah are you
talking about association
well it is in part association but the
way in which
the psychology of association has has
worked is it thought you just have a
bunch of little bits and pieces in your
mind just associate some together
marilyn mt is talking about
something going beyond that
it's not just a bunch of data that's all
arranged in the right way
which evokes each other
you literally see in the wood
the meaning of it which includes that
grain
having a certain hardness to it which
you you can only experience by actually
touching it right
he would say you're not just
experiencing that through
remembering okay you've gone and touched
wood before you can actually see things
that you've never experienced
and read into them meanings that that
they could have
when you look at certain dishes have you
ever looked at certain dishes and said
no i'm not touching that i'm not eating
that um how did you know not to eat it i
mean it could be that you actually ate
that before you're like man last time i
ate that terrible tasting you know i
better lay off of that but there's some
things you can look at say
i i i've never for example eaten rotten
meat that was so rotten that it had you
know flies or anything like that
but i don't need to i don't actually
need to have that experience to know
that
um i wouldn't like that and that it's
probably gonna taste awful
you know
uh yeah
we talked about slippage as uh like
certain modalities get weaker because
there is a slippage
right oh so there's a strong sense of
snow in something you tend not to
like what it looks like per se it
depends on the smell though doesn't it i
mean there's some smells that you they
might heighten your your experience you
really enjoy them so um would you say
there's a cap on all that mobilities
come back together is there a camera can
yeah there are thresholds
for we can only listen to sounds that
are so loud
before we're like you know
going crazy and we can't pay any
attention to anything else
and if it's one continuous sound it
could probably be a bit louder than if
it's like you know jarring
and like that at the same time
i guess there must be things like that
with taste
um
once you get beyond a certain hotness
right for somebody like me i i'm not
really good with super hot food
once you get these be out of certain
hotness at all it's all just
ungodly hot to me right i don't have
that
that sensation it's like that with with
visual things too you guys perceive
the world in in brighter colors than i
do because i'm i'm 42 years old and my
eyes are you know getting getting older
and you have that to look forward to
yourself
so
soak it up while you can right look
around as much as possible not so much
at the computer screens but at you know
real life things so yeah there are
certain thresholds and when one of them
is is too high it can keep us from being
able to pay attention to
other things so let's uh let's move on
now and i'm going to talk about
less about marilyn pontian and more
about this guy aristotle
so we're going far back in time
and i'm actually going to end up at the
very end telling you a little bit about
taste and the history of taste um
drawing a
little bone to you guys you might say
um aristotle is interested in the way
the senses work and park is he's
interested in everything
he is one of these kind of people who
you'll see this
high performers in any field
are generally not the people who are
only interested in that field they're
interested in everything else too
they're interested in one thing in
particular at that time but they tie in
everything else and they pay attention
everything else aristotle's like that
himself
and he is
focused in some of his works
on
the senses
so
it looks like i have to
wrap it up a little bit get through this
fairly quickly so i'm going to skip over
some of the things i was going to talk
about aristotle is talking about
the
estatia part of this
we get the word aesthetics from this you
know aesthetically pleasing and things
like that
and
the stasis is the greek word for
sense
or sensation or perception
and you could you know you can contrast
it to things like
memory you know when you're perceiving
something right now
you're actually it's in front of you
you're perceiving it
think about you know the taste we've
talked a lot about smoking and tobacco
nobody's smoking right now but you can
remember what the taste is like can't
you
so that's different than sense
perception
and i'll talk a little bit about time
and memory if i
have the time
aristotle's interest in how do our
senses work and how do we put these
things together is it just association
or
is are we actually do these do these
senses bleed into each other and
complete them themselves in a certain
way
so he talks in a book called the day
animal and i'll make a reading list um
dr shock asked me if i'd make a little
reading list for you guys so i'll make a
lot of kind of like reading
recommendations about this
he talks about the different senses in
the day animal which is about the soul
and he says a couple interesting things
he says each sense has its own specific
object okay that makes perfect sense to
you right
what is taste about you know you put
things in your mouth and actually taste
them
smell is about odors sound is about you
know waves that you're getting through
the air
sight is about things that you're
looking at
each of them has its own modality we
would say using the language that we did
before
now he also says that touch
is more
differentiated than the others
and that makes sense right heat and cold
we feel that through touch pressure
smoothness and roughness you know this
is pretty smooth
we don't have anything that's
particularly rough around here i know we
don't because it's a nice smooth
classroom but you know sandpaper would
be rough right your eyes only take in
color
your ears only take in
sound
taste you know what how many tastes are
there
basic tastes
five six yeah aristotle actually thinks
there's eight we'll talk about that in a
moment
it's kind of an interesting question how
do we go from eight down to
four or five or or six
um
aristotle also says we have we have
specific senses
and then there's some things that are
common sense of bulls he thinks that
we actually
process
in our our mind
we process things and we bring them to a
kind of unity
your eyes and sight does not see a
person as a person it just sees colors
so how do you actually see
how many people in that one two three
four five six seven eight eight people
sitting around you know at a table does
that count right
yeah okay good um
something more is going on than just
your eyes
how do you perceive movement
well you know you're just saying your
eyes are only saying color is changing
how do you actually perceive these
things well there's something that
unites your senses together and this is
why it goes beyond just association
of you know sense data there's something
that in the very way in which you
perceive things ties things together in
terms of what the different senses are
providing
providing to
so the senses also ties together with
pleasure and pain you know aversion
things like that
and they form a unity he says in actual
perception
the other thing that he says that i'm
going to sort of skip ahead to
i'm not i guess i won't talk about
memory or time or those sorts of things
aristotle uses this word
stasis
in a broader sense in his works in one
of his books called the politics which
is about political science he was one of
the founders of political science
he says that we're different than the
other animals
because we have perception
of
not just pain and pleasure
but what he calls moral qualities
and aesthetic
qualities and what would these be
these would be things like
right and wrong
just and unjust
noble and base
honorable and dishonorable aristotle
actually uses the same word the stasis
perception for those
and
you know there's there's a lot more to
be said about this i'm not i'm not going
to say much more about this
but i think what's kind of interesting
about about him doing that is when you
think about how you perceive things
how you look at the world
you don't just you know things that are
the moral qualities good and bad right
and wrong
you don't just infer those those aren't
just concepts those are things that you
can actually see in people in events
according to somebody
like aristotle
in actions you can look at an action
like merrell palm tea talks for example
about seeing somebody who's angry and
that anger is evident in the fist we're
in the you know the face right we think
our angry faces are the tone of the
voice
you perceive that if you're writing
about that some people would say
ah you're inferring too much all you
actually see is somebody you know
you know
gripping their hand there was this very
naturalistic way of writing at one time
where you weren't supposed to go beyond
the pure you know
observation well no the way in which we
actually do observe
is if i go like this
you're not just having a stimulus you
know response of oh i better get back
you perceive a threat right
you perceive a threat that's synesthesia
working right now
now imagine this again applied to dishes
conditions themselves be
presented in a way that slovenly or
meticulously
when you see somebody presenting a dish
meticulously are you just is that just a
judgment on your part that has nothing
to do with your senses it's you know
pure concepts no you actually perceive
it and part of becoming a a chef is
learning how to perceive these things
better and better and better
so you can decide the tricky cases
you know
when is somebody being cool and you know
slinging something out when somebody
being a jerk that's something that
aristotle would actually say
maybe you could actually perceive that
yeah so is aristotle saying that moral
qualities and aesthetics is something
that you don't learn but it's something
in nature the sense that you are born no
you do learn you and you get better and
better and better yeah and and you can
also learn it badly so that your your
moral sense is all screwed up you know
like you think that
um hurting people
you know just for the sake of hurting
people is the best life possible right
that person screwed up and you you don't
actually have to like
get a textbook of psychology and like
look through and say oh yeah
they fit the concept of the sociopath
you can actually look at people like
that and you actually feel the you know
hairs on the back of your neck right
you're like stay away from that guy
we can go wrong in the way that we
perceive things that's that's a very
good question we can be trained to see
things wrongly
we can misperceive
and we can you know when we have fears
right this is something i think all of
you have to face as students part of
your your process of learning is
learning how to recognize and overcome
your fears that you have that you didn't
even realize that you had
and not let those interfere with your
process of paying attention to to what's
actually in front of you
um that takes a lot of training doesn't
it it's a kind of educative process
so this is about as far i think as
we'll go there's a lot more to be said
about this it's a very fascinating
subject
so what i'd like you to take from this
is this notion that when we're
talking in sense language
it's quite okay to have these things
bleed over into each other
that's the normal thing that's what
you're doing all the time
you're just doing it below the threshold
of being conscious of it now you're
actually trying to be conscious of it
and you're going to do that in your
practice as chefs you're going to do
that any of you become food writers
you're going to do that
and you're probably going to do that in
other fields that you go into as well so
any any questions any other questions
yeah um i don't know if you've seen this
show kyle xy
kyle likes why you've seen no i haven't
he's like born practically at the age of
16 and like so he'll have like no
experience oh
so
do you think someone with no prior
experience would see like a dark
alleyway and they'd see here or they
wouldn't see anything
that's a good question
aristotle would say aerosol actually
talks about our need to
experience things in part through touch
to be able to figure out what they are
so if you've never been in you're going
to say someone who's never been in that
kind of situation
well
instinct only explains the the response
it doesn't explain the actual perception
instinct is what you get after you're
starting to perceive things that's why a
lot of times our instincts which are
pretty good don't kick in when we need
them to kick in right
um yeah i guess this kyle xy guy would
be kind of kind of in a bad bad spot
well i did promise that i would tell you
about aristotle the eight tastes you
guys want to stay a couple of minutes
and i'll tell you about this
that's kind of an interesting thing so
as i was looking through the dianomon i
hadn't realized this before i knew that
in the ancient world they recognized
more than four tastes because you know
we're used to thinking in terms of what
sweet salty bitter
and
sour yeah and then you know we
supplement that with spicy perhaps which
is you know barbs sticking into your
tongue and then you know they've brought
about umami they talk about that
um but for a long time views back in the
50s just before tastes
now john demaski who is writing much
later than aristotle but who's still an
early ancient guy he talked about eight
tastes and when i saw that i was like
wait a second now i know in chinese
cooking there's there's the five tastes
and there's there's actually more you
know they recognize that but where is
this guy coming from he's a greek
writing back in you know the ancient
period
he's talking about eight tastes
that's pretty differentiated that's
pretty sophisticated and this guy is not
a cook
or a chef or even like a you know food
per pure or anything he's a philosopher
what does he know about taste right
when i was reading aristotle again today
he started prepping on this
i saw a passage in there where aristotle
is actually talking about eight tastes
so
what are they he thinks that that um
and he arranges in kind of a strange way
he's got um sweet and bitter as being
like the two biggest tastes the ones
that are most opposed
and i have to go back to the greek to
figure out exactly what he's saying
because then he says under sweet you
also have succulent
that's what the translator translated it
as and under bitter you have salty and
bitter and salty we differentiate right
those are two completely different taste
profiles and then he says there's four
in the middle
four what are they
well he says there's astringent
acid acid we know what that is right
sour
pungent and if we wanted to figure out
what pungent means we can look at the
example that he gives time
what would you say time the the herb
what what would you associate that with
savory maybe
aromatic okay so we could we could
associate it with that and then he says
there's harsh and astringent
astringent is probably something similar
to numbing
you know those what were those chinese
uh
peppers yeah the sort of numbing
astringent makes your mouth kind of
crawl up they recognize that back in
aristotle's day i don't know what they
were eating
that they recognized that i haven't done
that research yet and then harsh is
probably i'm guessing in greek picos
which means something like spicy so they
were recognizing
eight different
tastes
all the way back in you know
fourth century
bc and this is a guy who's not a cook
he's just a guy who likes to eat
apparently
um and he was differentiating so think
of what the cooks themselves must have
been talking about
i'd really be interested in finding out
how it went from recognizing eight back
down to only only four
you know because that seems like an
impoverishment what is that do they come
by
i don't know
perhaps well succulent could be like
funny
yeah
although he uses honey as an example for
sweet
so